all right and we are laughs welcome to
the Isle or podcast in the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 170 it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
and we've got the switch light reveal
Final Fantasy 7 remake exclusivity the
big three moving consoles out of China
in exile and Xbox game studios
Plus Gears 5 smoking to discuss so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord whose continued rise
as a content creator is truly
outstanding to watch develop whether it
be is extremely informative videos
straight shooting podcast team or his
hilarious approach to gaming there's no
doubt on social media who the king of
the saltiest take is introducing the
creating host of the saltiest gaming
youtube channel and the saltiest gaming
podcast the profile of the recent new
born to the realm and the Lord whose
xbox Mike turned into a pillar of salt
it gets filed impressive more launch
Arizona and making his return into the
realm of the Lord's mommy Lord salty is
gaming how you doing sir
good morning it's good to be back
goodness
I'm surprised I'm still awake but hey
that's why I haven't a Red Bull here cuz
it keeps you awake when you're running
off a few hours of sleep a man it's good
to have baby number two I can't get
enough of her honestly cuz she's so cute
she has brown hair and I think she'll
have new eyes I'm not sure cuz the eyes
are kind of gray in the beginning but
yeah it's good and it feels like I've
been gone for like you know salute Emily
Rose is what we
[Music]
rolls future of the brown salute salute
back so in a minute shout out to your
team man had a good time I was actually
lying on TGS P you're not saying so that
was dope what's the FC violent on the
track oh no right centering on and hyena
yet the main gets you got you got a
whole new squad I like yeah you it's the
rotations real you know throughout life
people have things changing but yeah I
love our our panel and our squad man we
we keep it real I try to I've been
throwing in gifts during the show you
know ask love to see the journey man
keep it up about a wait your avatar now
really fits in the realm of the laws I
had to say all right I'll uh I'm with
huge bear than avatar that I was down
with the Saltine I was I do like the
picture though you know what I've missed
oh I miss his original meat into his
video that joins the club bagged up
great in leveling up you are a no so
you're Reno we got the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original Lords here in the
realm and the roundtable my calls are
the core most my brother from another
mother the difficult game Conqueror and
the heart of the young wolf mommy
doing pretty good uh actually doing this
whack I can't cuss but I have to replay
the forsaking expansion so oh yeah I'm
definitely serious okay I was told that
there is there is there is cheesing to
be done so I you know I'm not gonna hand
with the photo Lord because that's
actually a good thing okay I'm gonna say
this to UM say this you know where I'm
rocket dogs what the hell are you a like
you
you know obviously there's a little bit
of difference but it's not that much of
a difference I just know what's going on
I see yourself we can materialize now
from heaven with cross and play which
common folk what I will do when that
actually occurs I will step over there
for a little bit because once once I'm
able to bring my stuff over see my
biggest barrier to that whole situation
was the fact that PlayStation was frauds
so they were holding everyone back
Bungie is no longer beholden to the
Activision grant that has souped their
soil so now are you saying the reason
that you weren't playing on PCs because
it's because Sony was being some fraud
that would you say is in fact no you
know I really I really got a giant
system over here and Sony was holding
everybody back because they
infrastructure as we can tell they
traded not too long ago was not able to
hold the cross they need to understand
so just our cross a was with Sony's
everybody start saving your bus they
start you can bring this over you got
Xbox game ball with the push of a button
a chance to look to the Lord and Savior
filled ominous well congrats on the kid
salty
you know we do it we do it
no first and foremost guru for most it
will never ever be any field ominous
land a dollar super chairs
thanks thanks for the two tiles super
jet from Phil Spencer
he was like I ain't gonna read what you
say but I'm a reader to die thanks for
the books
yeah anak and of course we have almost
the silver gay we live with a single
player selfish experience it also Sasha
Thomas mr. Omar profile Illuminati and
lore patreon of the iron bank mommy lost
sovereign how you doing sir
don't forget something you know what is
not a dig at your expense at all is
hilarious this is like that it you
finally had it something and then you
just gotta go extra with what we already
believe that at for the ending all right
buckle up baby put the mouthpiece in
because it's about to be a bumpy ride
you know what it is right now back
before bounce it back up my booster seat
on and everything good like I go no go
to worry about this right here super go
left I'm gonna make sure I go right
Pacha you win Mutombo we're not gonna
score that basket this is what happens
when you have a what I've been playing
so yeah I'm just like King said of this
oh it's just either game console hold on
haven't you said you play Final Fantasy
7 always like the past three months okay
what's a game where they face the pan
like you mean the first to be like I
played this one who jumped the gun
because I was like switching the bushes
for me yes I picked up that
blood-stained on that switch early on
boy boy did you get your money back I
have gotten my money back and I have
gotten the proper Xbox one next version
s yeah he just ate it it's gotten some
patches to improve it but it's never
gonna be 60 after playing it at 60 I
don't wanna play anyway any other way so
nobody you know what they said that the
Unreal Engine doesn't do as well as
other consoles on that one system and
it's because the Tegra how the Tegra is
built right doesn't handle the
information as well as went down to up
what unreal and seemingly having that
much issue as in like you know a lot of
the unreal stuff was able to scalable
but it's very strange to me yeah it's a
2d I mean it's a 2-d game with with 3d
polygons but it's I mean and the game
really is beautiful or just game is a
great game so it really takes that
Symphony other knife formula it really
is like a true successor to that so if
shout out to Phil Dominus I tested in
getting past
I'm sure it'll be that little boy
definitely and I yeah that's pretty much
it I play some more Assassin's Creed do
it like I can play like I can't wait for
X cloud so I can just like play and like
you know whatever like grind and finish
that game eventually that game is just
too much it's just bigger than X cloud
you do you understand like I fantasized
yesterday because um I were I was
setting up next year um you know our
marketing campaign and all right going
forward towards III 2020 and I was
putting the outline of the t-shirts and
thinking about exactly where in
Hollywood we will arrest that and it
just came over me that next year I'm
just gonna take my controller mm and I'm
gonna go and we gonna get busy cuz
addict me an addict Oh addict I do I
apologize to you because I think the
text came off a little salty not to no
pun intended
oh and I think you heard me like wrong
or whatever but I never got a chance to
clear it up and I looked at it the other
day I was like but I wasn't going at U
of with this year's marketing campaign
with no iron Lords against the world
yeah iron laws versus the world was a
fiasco shout out shout out to all the
dudes that didn't have the gas money to
get there and didn't wanna bring traffic
to get to the ring but you know I'm not
I'm a salty funny thing about it because
I would have drove to you I'd have
brought that controller to you and gave
you that smoke but nobody wanted that
smoke aka the XS game ooh
out of combat sports king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement ooh love it
Lord King how you doing sir I'm doing
terrible actually as y'all can see oh my
bathroom messed up so
we had I had turbines down here y'all
air drying everything
none of the statues got harmed I
remember you guys I told you about the
Shelf collapse and I'm gonna do a video
about that you didn't get any statues
this week as you can see the area right
here got some boxes on it or whatever
but um the reason why you didn't get it
because I couldn't video record because
the noise it was literally like dudes
was down here like then it was a team
just blowing air and it was so loud
inaudible we had to just you know get
out of here and not be around but um
that uh statute all combat talk all that
stuff will be up soon so I do apologize
for I know you got real life that is
definitely excusable so like what as far
as game add you that chance to do any
gaming what everything okay so is this
thing called last station if y'all
haven't played it it's in-game pass
right so is it's a 16-bit side-scroller
and it's like a horror game and it's
it's I don't know it's like a drama
horror and is a train game so I'm
playing it and then find out that the
city's is overrun with zombies and it's
so nice and it's so much fun to plays
inside game paths if you got game pass
go check it out
of course I've been doing destiny trying
to get my own bad juju shoutout to hot
monkey Chris and bone and everybody else
who's been doing the green Mason loops
and it's a one more game that I played
that was digging in my crate Oh forces a
seven I'm playing it remember I
purchased it when the system came out
with X enhancements on it I was all over
that so I'm trying to finish it up I my
fraud behind turn the game on why 35
cars popped up was like you got 35 cars
for free the past and
to drive at our stuff like your car is
technically driving in other people's
courses so ya always get points and all
of a sudden you haven't played it for a
couple of months you gonna give up you
know you know nobody somebody was home
we'll get some 2-hundred what you call
his driver tall whiskey's Robert always
it was right really is one of those days
with video games put you in a place yeah
yeah yeah for you bro that's what's up
getting that fours it in you know and of
course one more thing one more thing
else we will have a big announcement new
to the Johnson family coming soon I
posted the other day because my fiance
purchased me portrait of Benji Lord
Benjamin Lord Damien passed early on in
the year and um um and she got a
portrait of him made so now I'm able to
open the box as his box with his ashes
is upstairs I haven't opened it yet and
I don't know how I'm able to confront
that situation I kind of like put it off
and yeah it's there but I have been
looking at a companion and I've settled
on one and she's beautiful she's a
two-year-old Frenchie and spoke with the
lady make sure the paperwork is in order
and we're gonna go pick up soon so I
just this happened and I can't bring in
a house with this nice loot on that man
we much love we sort of love going out
to you man we've all been in and I got
tell anybody and like that's why I like
I I know me as a person it's so off me
you know saying because if I lose an
animal it is literally the equivalent of
a person and you actually about to you
because you send me something that
really made me understand that you
understood exactly what I was going
and like you being as a friend or family
member that really meant so much to me
you really have no idea I still I
captured that screenshot a screenshot of
that and people don't understand animals
is really rare finally a part of you
it's crazy yeah
even more so because like I said the
day-to-day interaction every aspect when
you wake up that animals and their pets
they're you know I'm saying like it's
even more so it's the deeper connection
want to give a shout out to oh sure I
was uh protecting privacy in a minute
shout-out to deaf singer he said King
hit me up on 407 I raced online I'm on
Pro shout out to j-dub aka Kratos was
good my King's just stopping back
quickly with the to our stupid shadows
going on Lord you already know DJ say
they saying the painting was great king
everybody's loving the pain and
beautiful yeah every painting was Sir
Benjamin your reign oh and of course we
have the Lord of the cooperative
experience in gaming ninja himself the
shinobi lore kognito spread never
illness in the realm of the ILP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so yeah we got to
keep the solemn theme yah but um
unfortunately but um I want to give a
shout out to MJ's a boss man please if
you guys know MJ's a boss he's honest LP
stream team he's been with us for a
while now he's really going through it
and shout out to the family and his
sister you know they're really going
through a tough or medical situation
right now MJ the boss is okay but this
is more so for the sister and everything
that's one of mine send some love out to
him y'all like I said checking on him
you know it's a rough time and we
definitely wanna send our thoughts and
prayers to the family and positive
positive thinking so just want to put
that energy out there for our MJ the
boss my man you already know and don't
ya so for me am is just been ghastly
hardcore now Destiny's good I'm back
baby
so back off the Guardian conjoint
finally get a chance to blaze and um I
might have to do a Cognito fraud alert
King what happened oh man let me tell
you wanna bet on them do you gotta say
his name
I know who he is the wrath world shout
to the Lord the Emperor is here I don't
know who he's referred to that's my guy
that's my guy Erskine that was his name
oh I just wanted to make sure that we
understood Rumple foreskin first I'm
checking out the fog and salute brother
yo Rumple um just to let you know had I
came across you in destiny with that
name I would have immediately added you
man with that type of sense of you need
Larry so like I said I killed some fraud
alerts out man cuz I'm I don't know if
shelter - look if she's gonna chat
Destiny's really hot right now there's
some some great activities an opera
slate Minaj really but here's the thing
there's this new activity right now and
it's called like the tribute hall and as
most of you know HQ is back the only way
to get bad juju a beloved weapon is to
play this mole so shout out to my lab my
podcast partner on Ibanez for the last
word we had a good discussion this
Friday and it was kind of like yo you
know I'm saying I love you know that
they doing all his cool stuff but like
this event wants man resources map
planning materials matte glimmer and
they like the way work solvers like you
do these bounties for him it gives you a
1% discount
each time 1% do you know how long you
got to be playing before these prices of
all these materials go down you can get
what you want to get Nate literally have
the gun lock behind it right so he's
like cog not it's good man just three
four weeks of grinding you're gonna get
check out your grinding longer than some
wars have had bro
I'm not trying to grow I want my bad
juju right so I'll be getting into a
little bit so it's no problem
so then I want to shout out another
person shot my man pyro gaming because
he's got a great video out right now
apparently there is a way to access
these materials much quicker so always
say is shout out to all you frauds
playing forage right now all of you and
I know why I play a forge a fkn duel
which I enjoy it's a quick question can
either if is me doing playing this game
right now to be is that make me a frog
like me playing it right now to do the
cheat you do what you gotta do cuz
there's everybody with that juju
you know shout out for the fire out of
super chat Jess style body show some
love my man must appreciate it but yo
Cedric my man I gotta tell you your
level of activity on Twitter is
outstanding I really must say that man I
do appreciate all that love shout did
dizzy with Attila weakly reminded that
King o saw and I cannot win you gotta
take your credit card and slide it on
the side of your right now first of all
I told you basically it would be $300 I
did we did three right and I'm not
Oh flag all I know if King loses
Toomey's I don't remember them bets the
only needs is out there that's it does
in the air is sovereigns neat actually
holding on because dizzy I don't know
what what you and dizzy got going on but
I think what it is is I think what it is
lucky dizzy wants your knees you know
why because I have massacred dizzy with
that art crap PowerPoint I just think
it's impressive how long you delayed
these knees as well when the system
launches throw that disc in and show me
that it can do that it can't they don't
have a person then it make a beautiful
looking system you know I would drop
dead on this block I try to crank people
just trying to get knees I'm not even a
part of that bit but I would rather be
if his prediction is going to ask for
money what do you do man look at there's
a card reader on the at in the side
place I don't expect up in the knee
segment I expect you doing a livestream
if you cut your knees off and singing
that is absolutely a joke that's
hyperbole but I understand this I
understand first of all they do not have
a bill still well over there unless they
can fish listen
they don't have don't listen big icons
will show you okay relax if they have
bill sandwich sony tomorrow then I will
be like oh I'm giving you the meat
straight up right now bill is on the job
it's over so just to clarify that it's
not necessarily because Sony doesn't
want to give their fan base you know
that the backwards compatibility for
free that they don't have that D you
need and the ability and the talent to
do it so they have to they at the charge
they only know how to charge me it is
the equivalent of right now see right
now we'll love to run a 40-yard dash
I can't right Sunni would love to give
you back back with compatibility
they can't it's over right so let it go
you I'm not getting it you really think
it's not really happen for you to make
that happen you have to pay them them
bucks you really it's like me in a chat
I can try to let that be the Destiny J
real quick
it's a shout all these frauds out here
who doing this playing boys we all don't
like I'm playing for is know that hot
and that new happening food and y'all
farming and shot so many brothers cuz I
got receipts all all your and my
keyboard all your all my friend I've got
to screech I got the receipts so yeah
I'll talk about y'all like that grind
you off fraud so that's just had to put
that up to Eddie how before we do now
solve would you all like to get into the
order brother there's some real crazy
stuff about the go long because they
don't they won't even tell us what they
talking about
so let me start with a disclaimer for a
city that
well we gotta start off a disclaimer
iron bank nor myself has had nothing to
do with this to Lord snow though and the
banhammer after after a record 1000
fraudulent submission the ire Lord
podcast gleam giveaway from Marvel
Ultimate Alliance 3 for Nintendo switch
we have a winner and just remember the
disclaimer the winner of the gleam IO
Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 giveaway is
none other than the Lord of salt and you
for real one for real for real way never
gonna hear I know I know you know it's
really every page so this is the
ultimate they're gonna feel like
ultimate race are you saying they're all
right but this one it'll be real quick
do not subscribe to the iron Lords
podcast before this unsubscribe and your
guardian rights and plead the fifth yeah
oh
he's a guest on the podcast and he wins
the gleam giveaway
congratulations salty I would have that
code for you later on this evening
Mike's a little mumbly just so you just
say you know cuz I'm gonna be a judge
but all you never keep it down for the
baby oh yeah baby down like we never get
it into this for what it really is these
low key texts install telling what to
say Bank receive no payment
JZ transactions we got to do with the
Lords of plan and lost salty has won the
Marvel Ultimate Alliance sweepstakes
we're gonna be doing a new one very soon
Lois um yeah he's actually been given
the royal treatment before all the way
back i LP 45 i wasn't it was like a
brand new year as when we started with
our salty so ah yes you we had such
tremendous game history obviously a lot
of Nintendo love in there but um you
actually missed out on a segment that we
did after which was on a top 5 so Lord
salty I need your top 5 video games or
franchises of all time top 5 okay number
one
Mario alright alright cuz I was thinking
about it and I thought it was first of
all how's my mic is it still mumbled all
right cool so I thought it was March
like Mario 64 that was my favorite of
all time but man Super Nintendo Mario
that takes skiing for me because I've
been playing Super Mario maker too and
just been doing some of those levels and
stuff so Mario is gonna be number one
for me halo is gonna be up there and
what else
Oh gears can be up there for me
doom you got to put doom up there cuz
I'm an FPS guy
I started playing doing about that I
feel like that no one good I can't wait
for the new doom and it's gonna be
awesome isn't right now is upstairs
there's so many good games out there you
know like could put our top 5 together
there's so many franchises that I just
love kids can I put Star Wars in there
and likes no because I battlefront and
there's all kinds of different Star Wars
games out there but yeah I just love
Star Wars so much the the old
battlefront games were really good for
me and just you know just a lot of
distortion I'm just gonna say saw the
Star Wars follow it as a French yeah
again yet the halo 2 Mario 2 dual Star
Wars the franchise I'm missing one more
what else there's a Gears yes there we
go strong less I like it top 5 has been
completed so we won't get into these
tablets got a lot to discuss now on this
one is actually hot off the presses was
a bonus topic I hit lost salty up last
night just to let them know this is
gonna be thrown onto this show and uh
it's gonna be uh no no puff puff pass so
uh we got to talk about it obviously is
very hot on the social media streets so
I want to bring this to you Lord salty
you're a big years fan um you know we
sorted news right now that looks like
they're armed
rod Ferguson and um these guys say they
definitely want to remove smoking in any
type of depiction of it in the game so
what are your thoughts about this I was
very opinionated on Twitter as usual
because I would turn up you know some
good old gifts of the the smallest
violin to play for people cuz they're go
heartbroken that smoking is not gonna be
in in their favorite video games it's
interesting how some of these things
trend but talking about censoring and
this and that but I think when it comes
down to is just created a vision and
there's a difference between the
- and honestly I think people need to
see that because rod himself talked
about how he never had a desire to have
smoking in his games and he you know
he's the creative lead there so when
you're talking about censoring and then
creative freedom for development for
entertainment you got to look at the two
and find that division because if ride
himself doesn't like smoking and there's
a good reason for that because he lost
some people or lost loved ones to that I
mean how could you question the guy and
say ah he's just doing this and that he
opened his heart up and he's trying to
tell people and yes does it coincide
with some of these eSport things yeah
sure they're always gonna try to make a
story about it but you know we're seeing
similar things like in entertainment
with stranger things they're talking
about not having smoking on there as
well in my opinion it's just smoking is
what it is it's just it's I don't want
to hurt people's feelings out there but
I will smoking is a bad it just kills
people you know saying and I know
there's a lot of people that are gonna
throw out well oh you guys are trying to
defend violence and video games as
saying that that doesn't cause people
who shoot up things this and that and
then you're saying oh they're gonna
watch smoking in a video game then want
to go smoke it's not about that man it's
just in my opinion you know it's just a
creative thing that he said he had a bad
experience with it and if he doesn't
want to end the game that's fine but the
media will just run with the story and
make something out of it animals I got a
quick question before I pass the
reservoir um what about um in reference
to like the fact that it did exist at
some point in you because the
counter-argument is gonna be like well
sex your ship and I'm saying like you
know now we we you know it might be
slippery slope or something like that do
you feel in this case is different
because of the fact it's the actual
developer himself like we were drawn
himself there's been some confusion with
the games and if they've had smoking in
there or not rod himself said there
hasn't been smoking in the first four
games and there's a lot there's a
picture going around of some dudes
smoking a cigar right I'm not screwing
and you guys know where that's from Oh
Rob there has no that was like years
three yeah there hasn't been smoking
since DLC of gears to well I guess he
said he said this guy's like you can
play him a multiplayer in Gears three
like a chunk or whatever like you know
yeah cuz he came out with the statement
I'm trying to find it on my on my feet
here he just said it's it hasn't been in
there so like in order to censor it it
has to be in in there and I don't know
if he misspoke or whatever but it's not
like there what was it for Devil May Cry
where there's actual nudity in the game
and then it's a different version coming
out on a different platform than that
sent you know you're you're actually
censoring that because you're spending
the nudity do you have a different
version of it
what he's saying is it just hasn't been
in there so it was a decision he made
you know it says see because I keep
seeing that picture floating around this
dude I've never seen pretty much what he
said cuz people were attacking this man
like our core over this and it's a look
like he has issues with smoking no it's
not censorship people need to understand
outwards that they really have no idea
what it really means okay censorship was
when you censor something that's already
been made to appeal to something or
because something was forced to do it
it's like it was never in the game you
can't says there's something that was
never in the game like look sure it's a
slippery slope a little bit you know
maybe he shouldn't pursue his own
persona on to his game but at the end of
the day it's his game to do what he
wants uh I and what's funny is there's
way more issues with this game that's
going on right now than smoking like the
fact that we haven't seen campaign you
know it just it just blows my mind it's
like you know he said from the moment he
had real you know collective power there
I guess it was wrong gears to when he
started getting a lot of influence into
the gears franchise
yeah he just cv got it took out okay but
it's not a big deal that first off it's
a post apocalypse world technically
there's probably not much smoke
going on in this world just uh I got
that quote here and I actually probably
read it wrong he just said just to
clarify
I've always been anti smoking and it
pushed back on having gear since day one
there was no smoking to remove from
gears four or five because there never
was any smoking to begin with so I guess
there was earlier on like you're saying
it was the only one yeah it might have
been in gears one but I don't know yeah
yeah yeah so we're talking about when
this guy has been in charge right when
the coalition was made he's in charge he
doesn't want that [ __ ] in his game so I
mean it's not there it's not being
censored he just has never liked it and
he gave his reasoning and I think it's
interesting that people would actually
questions question the man's integrity
especially when it's involved in a death
you know like I mean at a certain point
guys this is video games and when
someone's given their word you got to
take him for the word and if you're
questioning their integrity I just don't
think that that's right because I I
believe this guy's telling the truth and
I think of the deeper meaning of them
what I think you guys are alluding to if
you know even if he came out and he said
we took out smokin - you know because
eSports is going to take us more
seriously with no smoking but like I
would even take that as a reason it's
like look people don't realize how much
eSports keeps your game a lot yeah so
it's like if someone just like yo don't
don't smoke in your game you could be in
eSports alright like it's not like we
was gonna be smoking in a poke
post-apocalypse world anyway so that's
gone like what people I will say that
you know this this was exaggerated to
the fullest when it comes to censorship
or any form I don't think this is
censorship but when it comes to anything
that even remotely looks like censorship
people for some reason act like the
entire world is being censored when
that's not the games in the Wraiths
world to us which had no one would
notice if he just kept it to himself so
he was asked a question
so we sprung is he supposed to not
answer questions because people are
going oh you know he didn't answer the
question on why the single play hasn't
been show
do you want to pick and choose the
questions that you want to answer sir
now I really don't think he thought this
is good know what he said it oh you know
what I don't think it should be a big
deal but anything that Microsoft does is
a big deal I believe there's a underline
and tone when it comes to Microsoft in
general I believe that it's underlined
and tone when it comes to their big
games coming out I believe it's fair
mongering and it's hate to be honest
with you they're looking for anything
too attached to this game inside some
negative form so it doesn't have proper
sales
I believe attacking Rod Fergusson where
to be honest with you demand listen i'ma
tell you I believe smoking is a
disgusting habit
I believe I lost both of my
grandmother's to that terrible addiction
and to watch them deteriorate in such a
manner it broke my heart and to this day
I would I would never pick up a
cigarette I would that will never
happened I think that happened to be
honest with you when some I took is
there I guess chakra smell cigarettes
cigarette smoke I'm like you still do
that who's still doing that this is 29
we're still actively reading the back of
the cigarette box that says causes
cancer you will die this is where I'm at
with this this is the thing all right so
that out the way we all know is a
disgusting habit have Ron Ferguson came
out and say yo this is disgusting habit
I don't promote it and I don't want it
in my game I don't care if eastwood said
they're gonna push your game what I
don't really care at all I really don't
think this is even a topic for you do is
that one cigarette smoking inside your
guests puff a pack of cigarettes while
you do put a pack to your mouth and let
it go and in the deteriorate on your own
but nobody needs to worry about some
video games some virtual smoke are you
saying
I'm totally fine with rods reason for
doing it I mean again it is his game he
can do whatever he wants and I think
that's an that's a more than valid
reason to omit it from the game mom same
thing if you would like add except you
would have come out be like look man we
you know we're trying to keep this game
in a forum where you know it's it's
appealing to all people who want it to
be an eSport a long-standing eSport and
that's something that affects it cool
but at the same time I do sort of worry
for me my thing is always outside
influences thinking affecting your
product is always something that I have
to sort of look at it with a side eye
because it's anytime again
I understand its business I understand
that you know it's not just oh you know
sales of the game day one or whatever
it's about the life of the game you know
in all of its iterations whether it be
the first the single-player campaign
whether it be the multiplayer stuff
would be the eSport stuff so I get that
but I have you know once you once you
talk about this this youth group that
came to you know the Turner Broadcasting
was like look we're not feeling this in
the game and then they sort of turned
the story into well yes we owned the
broadcasting rights to your eleague so
that's sort of that you know it's it's
like if you don't do what I say you have
anything up something it's like they're
getting squeezed a little bit like oh
and that bothers me but beyond that
again I just if that is the case and
you're gonna get more pushback from this
just stay with rods version and that's
fine and that's that's more I'm more
than happy with that not for you got me
saw me you won't actually on the same
kind separate town with it
cuz it's like like the whole thing is
funny to me because I don't even
remember I must be a gift for I don't
even remember gears character smokey
like where was I that I didn't remember
it but but he was yelling out it was
cold training I was like really you know
some others talking about but I said man
okay
so I don't mean to cut this part it just
irritated me because it was inside my
chat this weird and do you really argue
these guys are really hearing what
they're saying
does it affect gameplay did the
cigarette smoke
blow it inside the motion not like Metal
Gear right so what you're thinking is
you know I can't light the bomb with my
cigarette now I have to go to the other
side and grab a torch light it I can't
just light it with the cigarette is this
stopping sir I don't understand how this
is an issue where is something is
aesthetic like maybe what if he said
okay well we're not gonna have any laces
on the characters if he can tie laces on
me boobs like is that a problem
I know I don't care it's not affecting
gameplay right so in that respect I'm
with you I do feel with solve is saying
no this is not only thing like if this
wrong fine rod is making a game roster
he'll want it I'm cool with that right
my only concern is this little eSports
League and people if they're if they're
stressing them who else do they stress
and how many people's caving and like
this year smoking's an issue next year
bloods an issue the right people's necks
tenaciously briefs no we all blame
Barbie doll games hate shopping just
making content on YouTube you see this
stuff you know I'm saying we think you
come out with more and more rules and
more and more guideline corporations
they want to make money and they want to
sell their product it is just like see
where you guys are coming from that
that's all I think obvious my thing
salty like yeah I'm all about the
artists vision right if the game creator
says hey I want it to be like how would
the second row thing right and they were
like yo is there no easy moffam like oh
well I already inked in life this is
Gary Coxe supports dirty lugs
listen Cognito now but it's all about
like I said it's so easy to hate Xbox
and PlayStation fans have nothing to
talk about
so everyone jumps on the a-train to play
its PlayStation great panel guys this at
the end of the day I get it it's just
you know I'm all about the vision I'm
all about the integrity of the artists
or the game creators original vision so
whatever that is even if I don't agree
with it you know I'm saying this stupid
games aren't right now it's like you
know murder simulator whatever I'm never
going about it you know I'm say it's
just not my thing but it's like if
someone's internet yo do you fam that's
that's your thing so I get it in that
respect so I just I just want to make
sure that we don't get into that great
influencing this is design the people
will speak we already been at this
doorstep already we were here with
Mortal Kombat with that blood and no
blood you know say go took a gamble said
we're gonna lead a blood in the game was
not superior to the patella Nintendo
game it was not superior but they have
blood and guess what versions so the
people will speak if they make a version
with the cigarettes in it and you buy
that one more and God bless I got a few
percent King all right now I demand that
you read dizzy super chat before you you
acted like you didn't exist a couple
minutes ago all right busy I gotta read
that right from dizzy
[Laughter]
I read it and it's up there you hear it
we don't know that red curtain that car
has closed right now mega he said zero
3000 smoking may seem small but we want
devs to tell the story they want to tell
not story they have to tell to keep
outside yeah did you guys see Kojima's
tweet about the mad Mickelson how oh
yeah who knows what he's talking about
the top so he just he tweeted this now I
had a whole bunch of pictures said yeah
Mads he smoked a lot on set so
originally his character wasn't gonna
smoke but we put it in the thing is with
that super chat I think it's gonna be
creative freedom obviously you're
talking about with story I think it's
always gonna be there but when you go
out to these multiplayer eSports type
games I mean I think that's when you
start going into this corporate you need
to deal with a protocol you know shut
out the bill Russian addict and kinks a
damage control I didn't see that it
wasn't blue I don't understand at what
point in time that was damage control of
me saying cognizant support dirty lungs
I will control everybody moving right
along this is a lot of context to this
so let me explain why all right this is
a back story and I appreciate you bone
for jumping in here and I cuz I was
never gonna say anything um you know
bone we we game all the time bone is
always there in the chat and you know
while he's working
um you know shout out to Phil Spencer
and the team for allowing people to be a
part of the gaming world while they
outside in the world alright um and bone
brought up this topic with the cigarette
smoking and you know he was highly
offended at it because even if it was
never part of the game what he didn't
like and what he doesn't want is any
form of censorship any form of bullying
developers and to pushing them into a
corner where they not really created a
vision of what they wanted and the fact
that addict even alluded to the fact
that is eSports um connotation to this
whole subject this stat is troublesome
and a point that they're putting big
money on the table and they're forcing
you to do something that otherwise lets
is not this 18 plus games job to teach
your kid not to smoke first of all your
kid if he's gonna be playing the game
all the way like let's be real here
these people the kids already smoke all
right
they already smoke so they ain't no
point in saying like that because they
already smoking they smoking in your
bathroom they smoking outside in the
back George they're going that out
though at the at the window I got my
game alone I got a really Eagle baby
alright shout out the Philly Eagle for
understanding how the King operates
you are a staple in our Sundays and I do
appreciate everything and everybody here
we go enjoying the show four colors and
[Laughter]
I get King in for this which is that
switch light yo was it was announced you
know saying you know it's a lot of stuff
going on and I go first you are going
first sir so well so basically you know
we got the announcement you know I'm
saying
Teno September 20th $200 it's gonna be
that a carrying case and screen
protector set for the Nintendo switch
light and obviously there are some
differences you don't say it's a bit
more different just set it up and stop
coming with it with the joint that you
doing right now the damage control
this is active you see how I was able to
you know who might get a dope and I'm
this is where the fraud comes in on me
yeah go get it go get it if any one of
my kids decide to say eh yo dad you know
I'm saying I want that um this is the
thing that I question if you buy it
doesn't that mean that you got it anyway
I'm supporting them I'm supporting if I
pretty front port unless now let me say
where the smart part comes in in in also
must call fraud on Nintendo right a
Nintendo pancake which I have dubbed the
pancake Oh pancake you flip it over
because that's all I could do okay no no
they took away everything that made the
switch unique and beautiful no hear the
sound story for the system he hates they
don't know I went out and purchased it
because it was able to do this in that
it was able to do something that my xbox
ex can't do place a pro don't know it
was people to do these things and it
stood on its own a man has definitely
went to the territory see they've been
trying to kill off the three TS
for a long time they didn't want
eight games for two different consoles
they want to make one game make it
Universal that you could take that same
game and play it on two different
formats right all right this is a
separate format this is no longer the
same format as a switch you got to stop
calling it this way kid can't switch did
you lose functionality with your current
switch I'm just curious current switch
unable to do the things we do us my
current switches like what the hell is
that the current switches like here's my
uh here's my younger brother that you
know here's my younger brother that's
that's from the bad side of the family
say something that will be highly
offensive but I'm not alright is an
undeveloped switch okay the fact that
you got these premature switch that
should not go out in the world okay
we'll give me the opposed to this you
know why they're gonna do numbers you
she don't understand that taken away
what made it nice listen that active
Rumble there's no me Bose what's up
there honey what's up what made it
special was a portability that was it
yeah I get that for you you're right
King bees I think what you fried out
that it was yelling out it can do all
this is a magical system it's fantastic
oh you took all that away I still want
it anyway are you happy that oh this is
great
burn that's what gotta burn with it
let's get saltier I'm very clear so team
robot is here in the realm how did you
feel about the switch light like what
what's your thought process on it you
know say oh is this a genius move by the
$10 you got with this you know I have a
lot to say about this last cuz it's just
Nintendo knows how to do business let's
just put it that way okay it's a perfect
time to put this out because they're
getting it in the market before pokemon
sword and shield is gonna be coming out
but honest the majority of people that
play pokemon play it portably okay so
that's number one business move the
reason why this is coming out when it is
don't get it twisted it's for this game
they want it to sell as much as they can
they will bundle it together this one
has about three to seven hours more
battery life which is amazing for
portable players right no it has in half
an hour it doesn't have three to four
hours battery life it has one dependent
on the game that's true so I mean I'm
just saying I'm just three to four hours
is not a true thing is a half an hour
it's six days the regular switch is six
and a half hours that is seven
continuous off from what I've read it
just says the original Nintendo switch
suffers from short battery cuz obviously
you have the rumble right you're taking
that out you're taking a lot of features
out to save the battery life but I have
a lot of negatives with this as well
this perspective it's gonna move
consoles so it makes sense for Nintendo
but I I've experienced some issues with
my switch and I play it a lot right I
get more than most I had some drifting
issues on multiple switches I had a
warranty whoa
for the first switch that I had I just
took it back got a new one but like some
of the games don't have cloud saves
right so you lose all your progress so I
didn't want to do that again fortunately
I looked up some do yourself methods to
fix the drift and I did that but they
don't have joy cons on this right so
right
nobody from Nintendo has come out and
said hey we added this issue with the
joy Kahn's where we fixed it with this
model and who knows if it's gonna have
the same issues now if it does and you
don't get a warranty and your [ __ ]
starts drifting you cannot take this off
it's stuck on on the actual device right
so number one that's an issue and also
your screens a lot smaller
you cannot dock it you cannot put a pro
controller on there you cannot play all
games right it's not gonna be playing
your problem one two switch stuff like
yeah motions that's like our I'm gonna
on fact you could play regular but I
know you're going I don't either
yeah so I love my switch because even
though I play it more majority portably
the thing is is like if my kid wants to
play we can play on the TV you know I'm
saying we were picking up we can the
thing that got me to buy a switch to
come back into the ecosystem was to the
ability to do that I wasn't forced to
play you know because that didn't really
draw me in if it would've little by
Evita and some other [ __ ] and only three
yes I never go brother I never did that
but at this point it's just about
options for people right they want to be
able to reach the market the you know
the $200 difference between $200 and
$300 the $100 difference there is huge
for people yeah they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna reach a market and
like I said it's just gonna pull both
them in 220 the end of this year with
Pokemon oh my god numbers just gonna
kill see that's why I see you just let
it to my point which is you know cuz
being a dis some disagreeing Lords here
on this panel about the success of this
thing um you know I just wanna know if
everyone put their knees on a laugh if
anybody else gonna win it MPD from
September on worthless in my no budget
yes I think there's a good chance
Lucinda wins every MPD this year and
that's a great idea
you know um oh that Lankan look lurking
for you King that's for you this I've
got can't be one thing once again not
read it once again
endo is fraud him and further displaying
why the switch in the trash in the bush
I'll be that way
Lunken I feel you and it is
disheartening Tendo pimps out there
crowd and I gotta tell you man they will
give you every iteration of the same
thing any way they can give it to you
and just like salty said this is me they
don't really care about you per se and
it's all about none of these companies
do all us fans out here with this crap
talking about my xbox and my playstation
and mice Nintendo no they haven't make a
buck Joe and this is exactly what it is
this is the ultimate maker book strip
away everything that made that nice if
you thought that was everything that was
in there for a hundred dollars that they
will move that was just a hundred
dollars I believe that you could have
took away more money I believe that that
system shoulda came in $50 with a fifty
dollar game to be honest with you
because you took away everything that
made it special you took away the screen
size you took away every functionality
that made it nice so sell it for 50
bucks oh we don't weigh everything that
was nice 50 bucks and give away $50 yeah
because you took away everything that
made it what it is this regular switch
still exists I think it's too much for
$200 I think it's too much
oh I can I agree with the price point I
think 200 a nice round number but I
would like to see in a 150 well I would
definitely like they've seen a 150 but
again it still it's just gonna kill
because the thing is this is what
Nintendo does right technically they
release a dumbed down version for
cheaper when they need push on and it's
the ideal time with Pokemon um I think I
know salty mentioned up like a bundle
they are Pokemon versions coming out
but I specifically said the game is not
bundled in all they go on the jury will
you buy the practice whatever whatever
three colors that coming out with that
launch and then they have the the
pokemon sword and shield versions of
that as well but those versions don't
come with the game we're gonna start
calling Nintendo out or maybe I like to
say Sony never supports anything
Nintendo had a 3ds took out the 3d stay
giving you something and it's hot for
two days and they be like now man let's
put that here last year look I bought an
$80.00 2d s for my nephew no clamshells
just one piece that doesn't fold with
Mario was it the new Super Mario
Brothers 2 80 bucks
he is happy as a pig in slop a real
quick shout-out to the $5 super chair
from Philly Eagle you do that green
there kid cuz I'm a 10 door man they
pull out stuff at crazy prices they leg
back hand and say you better bring me
that money and fans sending the money so
you say sue Philly work it out I want to
thank all the 95 people 97 now you're
watching you know definitely at that
like button to hit that like button King
loves the switch man listen to that
listen is that's holding out like then
you just don't do it but i'ma tell you
right now hit that like button if you
want to hear what I'm gonna say next we
finish up - because I'm sob I just real
quick question to your point do you
think this effectively now switch like
effectively kills off the 3ds I think I
mean the only thing that can kill off
the 3ds is a Nintendo not making any
more games for it Nader's have to decide
they're not gonna make any more games
for once they do that yeah the 3d s will
die but again this on its own no I don't
know it only picks up guys I want the
world to hear me right now I want every
last person out here I want you to go up
to the mountain
I want you to get your credit cards I
want you to login right now and I want
you to kill off this switch Minnie porky
to buy A to D s and a 3ds
I want the sales numbers for 2d s and
three years to spike so far to the room
that the switch Minnie never makes I
wanna do eight I wanted to die on
arrival
alright so please everybody go out there
right now even if you just purchase it
for one month and bring it back on the
29th date please go out and do this so
you support the man no I support the
killing of the Minnie I want them dead
Oh how would you prefer to kill the time
I want them to buy more three TS
and more to Diaz's so when they see the
sales Nintendo has no choice other than
the killing many before the mini even
get to our shores let it die alright I
just want to state that here at the iron
Lords podcast we do not support killing
console for no reason exactly anyway we
gotta get it looser red I'll be at the
end of the day another genius move my
grandfather pocket once again greats
Gregor now but all jokes aside I do here
with Jesse I do it just say I mean it is
limited feature just no doubt this is
not going to be fair one for everyone
who has that existing switch for all
that functionality
keep your switch you're fine this is not
for you oh yeah oh yeah I'm prompting
about the gray one thing went great like
this thing obviously does not sell but
for me I'm a big proponent of a
dedicated d-pad that's one of my big pet
peeves with the current switch those
that that's not a d-pad it's literally
buttons in the d-pad form so that's
number one
happy honest likes of you know I play
exclusively portable I'm never docking
the switch at home when I got Xbox PC
and PlayStation and I don't want to see
the 480 I don't want to see you know saw
the death second Nintendo stay finessing
gamers the kings of it listen man this
not for you that's a gross a snuff us
but there's guys like again could only
play it portable now this is what King I
have to give it up the kingdom for all
these features being removed amiibo IR
Rumble not docking besides the price you
know my major issue is that battery life
need to be much longer than this yeah I
can only get in a half hour to an hour
more like that's that's a little suspect
to me I thought for sure we'd get you
know two hours more and yeah the screen
is a little small shot the cop out to
here's how no man I don't know combat
the screen a little smaller smaller and
I have issues with it anyway as it is
now here's my thing now as long as they
don't remember they don't feed a 2.0 us
now memoir Vita first came out had only
known and then they came out with
version two and it was class Nick pays
battery was crazy
I gotta see so maybe they are keeping
that screen there's just a little small
the same exact screen with the same
exact resolution mom the thing with it
is the chipset net suicide I eat it did
you know it look like 480i how you did
you know I've seen is a different
chipset the chipset that's inside the
original switch is called a Logan and it
this this there's no switch mini to
standstill
it's called Miyoko um and it's a direct
take on Wolverines lineage their
companion chipsets
she is faster than Wolverine or faster
than the Logan ship said if you can go
to digital foundry you will see a great
video up on the topic of the switch so
you can get understanding
aren't they also at replacing that
chipset in the original switch like you
gonna start whatever is coming off the
production lines gonna have that new
chipset sled to my next point I like do
you think now solve and king-like do we
still think switch pros come in do you
think that the successor this would be
so much that is like there's no Neil I
where do we think switch Pro now have to
think
comes because they always do that they
give you a lesser version and then they
give you an improved version and what's
gonna happen is the original switch is
gonna drop by 50 bucks at least and then
the light is gonna drop by 50 bucks at
least and then the new premium version
will be back at that 300 price point
whatever it is and I don't know how
premium is gonna be over the original
switch because they're now not big on
big upgrades so it still may be
disappointing but I still see it coming
so salty do you think that the switch
Perl comes out at the same time as the
PlayStation 5 and the the Scarlett or do
you think it comes out a little bit
after once they died down with all the
rhetoric I think is gonna be coming out
after because it you don't want to go
neck and neck cuz like the pro version
of the the switch is not gonna be
anywhere close to what these are so you
don't want to confuse people or try to
say you're in some kind of a power
battle or you know I could see it
march/april I mean yeah but I do a small
team not to say they can't come out
either way it's just where there's smoke
there's fire so we've been hearing about
ro we heard about the mini like I like
the the mini version I don't know how
long ago I heard like a long time ago
over a year so we've been hearing about
the pro the pro is just it's gonna come
out but they do their own thing you know
so they'll put it out they need to put
it out when it's separate you know yeah
I'm interested to see what Pro really
means to Nintendo you know like what
what's a B Tegra 2 band ID tag return
but but let's move on except our kids
he's gotta run so I'm getting this topic
in now we've changed the order King man
you got a phenomenal one what is going
on in China man all right so this is
courtesy or and outdoor friends in Rome
fellow Lord
so one of the content creators that I
actively watch and I go to for my
information along with Colt Eastwood and
salut um now he put up something because
I really never paid in on mine I never
paid attention because I don't like to
get political on um on the podcast I
don't think that is our platform and I
don't think that is our lane I think you
guys come here to have a good time and
sometimes when you get political you
start to get very divisive yes um but
this is where something comes and it
actively affects us facts all right so
the new administration or the current
administration that is an office right
now is doing these things called tariffs
now I've never heard of terrorists
before this administration oh I've never
paid it any mind they became a great
tool for this current administration now
the fact that China and the current
administration in America is at a trade
war this tariffs that is being put upon
China where it's taxing their imports
right now China in turn has put tariffs
on America which is taxing our exports
right now we import damn near everything
from China right we all China trillions
of dollars now this is where this
affects us our consoles are being made
in the same plant in China the
PlayStation the Xbox and the Nintendo's
are all being made in the same plant
like right next to each other
okay now to export these to us to import
these systems to us it will cost at
least from what they're saying estimates
is like two to three hundred dollars
more than we were actually really gonna
pay so this is going to affect us in the
bottom line who's ready to pay for a new
Xbox Karluk eight hundred nine hundred
dollar Edition who's ready to play for
the PlayStation 5 because a lot of you
guys and broke guys out there got that
PlayStation because it was cheaper and
you know nine hundred dollars made a big
difference made a big difference to me
when I purchased four of them so now
that it's eight to nine hundred dollars
if the system's was to drop now
with the current tariffs in place it
will force the prices of these systems
to go through the roof
mm-hmm and my question to you guys is
how do you feel about it and what we
really can't do anything to stop this
yeah I mean real cost also sorry no no
the expanding on the title on topic
Microsoft and Sony is actively looking
for plants in America where they can
offload some of the costs in producing
these new systems right but this is
where you come into problems with
inferior quality and different type of
issues because if something is made in
the same place you know you're gonna get
the same product you can get the same
stuff but when you got duals fuels one
being made in America and one man made
in China something's gonna go wrong
yeah you talk about letting quality a
lot quality control stuff not get you
and that was the point I want to make
before we give it to the rest of the
laws oh oh a little baby cat salute
salute salute definitely may hit that
like button you up like how you saw that
that wasn't color I'm watching you guys
grow every week and come here and talk
with us and listen to it I really
appreciate you guys every week oh man
you have no idea you'll make my heart
sing yeah man I must love definitely see
this shot the Deaf sing with the $2
super check I feel for my USA Lords hope
I remain unaffected the last part of the
point that you're making I wanted is
that as a result the big three seem to
be kind of like taking action right they
seem to be like wow this is already
squashed like from what for - and now
Nintendo has moved a portion of his
switch manufacturing to Vietnam
so there are some proactive strikes
going on so salty let's get you going
this is a great time I got no tea so
watching I guess you guys talked about
it as well what you hope feeling on this
whole tariff thing in in consoles you
know we talked about this multiple times
on the podcast Trump's friends to
increase tariffs on goods produced in
China thing is is the idea of it
whatever we're not gonna get into
politics uh but
fact that Microsoft Nintendo and Sony
may need an official letter and sent it
to us as talking about how it would
affect technology and prices is insane
to me when I saw that the alarm started
just going off right because the thing
is is like they're not gonna just get
together and make a letter for no reason
right serious yeah you know they know
what's going on and even if you know the
they kind of got squashed because you
know Trump kind of took a step back from
it doesn't matter it doesn't mean that
you know eventually it could happen so
that's why you're seeing the migration
that's what we're hearing because you
know it was cheap to produce in China
and and that's why all all the consoles
were being made over there when I was
doing my research originally it was hard
to kind of get the the the 100% of where
stuff was going on because the
PlayStation 4 definitely was being made
over in China
you look at Microsoft it was like oh
they have plants all over the world and
stuff like that but majority is made in
China the fact matter is is gonna be
interesting going forward because you
have Google stadia out there right
they're starting their thing and we got
cloud gaming on the horizon thing is you
could say what you want about Google
stadia and hire the hard these next gen
systems are gonna walk wire and if these
tariffs do go into effect it is going to
affect everything it's gonna affect
everything man cuz like King was saying
who's gonna go out there and buy you
know that for the majority of based
console owners who's gonna just go out
there and pay $800 for a system and it
could be a reality and it affects gaming
in general and what direction things are
going so it's interesting going forward
maybe not in the short-term maybe it's
gonna take some time but I think
eventually it's going to have an effect
on the way gaming is going I have to and
I've been clowning on Google stay do a
lot because of some of their issues but
if they get their infrastructure and
their first party together and they're
able to do their thing it's if you had a
choice between 4k gaming on stadia or
paying 900
for a next-gen console I think you might
pause and think of it you know oh my god
plans already starting in place already
talking listen and on the real you
above all you know you and Brad you guys
will open arm to us and remember that
extension is all the way given to you
all right out so I'm like and you don't
want to miss this is the one where we
act over you don't want to miss where we
gonna be at boy um I just want to say
this just one thing on this topic right
do you think that once the tariffs and
stuff went out the contingency plan
because they already saw what stadia was
doing that Microsoft can hold off on
their system and get that cloud out
there mmm
that X cloud because if the X cloud is
giving you the same functionalities and
power of the scarlet and it can come in
at that cheap price because the prices
they talk about is $60 problem King is
right now they're at 1080p max with the
NEX cloud and that's based off of the
the server racks that they have so they
are gonna increase that right they're
gonna put it up to starlet levels but
that's not gonna be for a while you know
I just want to get you somewhat before I
give it a ji1 arm touch on something
also you salty you have mentioned in
reference to the seriousness of this
public document again this is signed by
Microsoft Nintendo and Sony as a joint
thing right and some of the bullet
points three key bullet points they were
like in particular tariffs on video game
consoles would a injure consumers video
game developers retailers and console
manufacturers to put thousands of
high-value rewarding US jobs at risk and
three stifle innovation in our industry
and Beyond and it
this this document is that length I got
to speak the whole area reach out the
whole get him back on here because I
really would love the the legal aspect
as far as where else they're going with
it but that's how serious this is when
the big three are coming together to
create a document to say hey US
government could you please change Fitz
we've got an issue so I want to get a
jacket that we get us office so Aaron
what's your feeling with this whole
thing on terra's how you know as far as
the seriousness with it and just where
do you stand on it and do you think even
like something like Google Stadium might
benefit as a result if this stuff is
still corridor no I think let me answer
the latter part of your question yeah I
think something like that could give
stadia a leg up when there's no hardware
involved right you know so automatically
off the RIP with that um like King said
you know I'm I'm reading up and learning
more about the whole tariff scenario and
what they all mean all I know is I know
that they've already had effects on
products that we're already buying one
year if you walk into a grocery store
you walk out with two bags it's $80 you
like y'all I bought with some oatmeal
what's up crazy
though you already feeling this so no I
don't think anybody no matter what your
pockets look like I want to walk in him
and pay upwards to eight hundred to a
thousand dollars for a console yeah if
we were already seeing like crazy
pricing going on like in the PC market
so imagine consoles are meant to be walk
out and walk to the store walk out plug
in let's go at a call at a value mm-hmm
nobody got time to be paying that much
for like you say when the big three are
writing letters that tells you something
real quick EJ to that point shout-out to
d'Estaing in the chat with the father
super chatty says remember no console
left behind one next can run old games
that whole forwards and backwards
compatibility that people clown could
benefit Xbox yeah I yes I get that I get
the fact that there maybe if if the
prices are through the roof and people
can't upgrade in the time from it they'd
like to that you can extend the life of
this generation with the x1x
but I think that since you've already
announced the next generation it's a
hard sell to tell people who were
psyched about moving forward like yeah
you could stay with your old console
another year or two or something like
that I think it's a heart for the
people who didn't plan on upgrading
right in the beginning of the next
generation is fine but for people we're
excited about it telling them that okay
you have this other option that you
already have that's not doing anything
for me but in particular wow I must say
something to the comment the Deaf thing
is said in a super chat I just want to
just piggyback on it real quick he said
forward compatibility sorry brother that
X is a doorstop it's done right there
yeah yeah you could bring that behind it
stuff forward but as far as anything
going forward no what will be that next
system would be able to do ex stuff so X
is weird it realize so if it stops right
there you're not doing any retracement
and you're not doing any hot stuff right
you mean theoretically a lot of that
stuff let's say that first year
year-and-a-half of stuff could run on
the X point it would it would be
considerably inferior to what you're
seeing on PC like super very no no
though that's what so let's get on attic
man way yeah with this man who would you
be willing to pay any increased costs
anaconda no problem we talked about 500
use about any con unless we will see I
will just upgrade my PC and call it a
day I got a switch to now buy that well
you know I want to point out a little
bit
because I caught neither didn't even
even remotely asked me my opinion on the
switch light wave obey my but I'm
actually for the switch light and I'm
buying you a Pokemon oh yeah at the end
of the day when it comes to this it's
like I'm already been told it's already
been backed off a little bit just like
salty said earlier I don't think this is
really gonna happen because politics is
about who got money who could pay who
can grease people's hands and who can
get stuff pushed and there is no one
that probably could do it more
effectively than to the big three they
just moved a production to Vietnam my
wives my question with that is that does
the console argument even move the
needle like if speaking specifically to
write speaking specifically to Trump I
don't think he cares about the consul's
any of you tell them oh the video games
aren't gonna sell yeah whatever no I
think you the way Microsoft needs to
approach it is is gonna affect pcs it's
gonna affect Windows Rob I think Sony
has to approach it more so from it's
gonna affect TVs it's gonna affect
stereos it's gonna affect that Nintendo
getting to tell you do any of that they
just need to lobby but hit nobody this
document as long as three of the parts
are it's like one of their their talking
points on the companies and video game
industry drive us economic growth and
technological innovation that's a big
point of this is their document then
part two video game consoles are highly
specialized products with complex supply
chains this is all their arguments and
then like it's like this document I
gotta get home I must reach out to home
and he says uh tariffs could hinder or
delay technological innovation in a
broad range of applications beyond
gaming so they're approaching it for the
three prong approach
outside of just how the video game
industry they're talking about how like
this could have tremendous ramifications
on other things so in the last point oh
here's a fifth one imposing tariffs on
video game car
would not be practical or effective to
obtain the elimination of China's
problematic IP practices so they trying
to attack it from that angle as well
this is and looking at the signatures of
vice-president Microsoft Corporation
you got Nintendo of America and Yvonne
Pritchard Jennifer Liu from Sony
interactive and team these are high
level names are this is one a corporate
side like this is very very serious
from what I understand they actually
held off on certain tariffs that would
have really affected it right now though
that would that was when he went to
North Korea right um they held off on a
lot of things I mean listen I do not
ever want to get political and if we are
offending anyone at this point in time
with talking political stuff we're just
talking to it to get you to understand
that this is going to really affect that
video game yes absolutely you got me by
Aaron in the chat he's saying main
important question is does it affect see
a thing is it will affect everyone
around the world because if you know
prices are increasing in the US then
they'll increase around the world it's
just they can't have one price for one
area in general so in general it will
just go up around the world that's just
the way I would happen Brazil we got a
monte shout out to you on this time this
time was phenomenal I mean it's just a
situation we're gonna have to monitor
we're gonna have to see how this thing
plays out we see steps being taken by
the big three and we'll see if these
tires go through or if they and if they
do if they don't gray if they do then
it'll be a situation where there's gonna
have to be continuously plans and you
know people moving manufacturing you
just hope like King said it doesn't
affect that that quality right the build
quality don't you know what red ring
I don't roll it was a good cake salute
for this way I know you got a roll make
sure your anniversary brother do your
thing Benji's birthday so I'm gonna
actually sit there and you know do a
little cake for my boy ask for some you
know give a little shout-out probably
open the box but already know when you
ready brother when you ready no you guys
it's been a great day salty I wish I
could be able to stay today Eric J thank
you for jumping in my seat though people
in
I got no doubt you already know so we go
move all while a king gets his swerve on
Oh Lord addict you are up and uh some
final fantasy actually do you want to
swap cuz remember I gotta get going
oh yeah this is a crazy day today that's
right so let's swap let's swap that's
right solve you up let's get what's
going on with in exile man
okay so shout out to a WCC F Tech um for
the article on in exile um so basically
I talked to Lee wasteland three
developer about how things have been
going with the game since they were made
part of Xbox Studios and what was most
interesting about what they said is that
it's basically how they feel that they
the collaboration has been great since
they got there they basically echoed
what other small studios have said well
all studios in the Xbox fold have said
is it basically Xbox at this point is
not trying to step in and control
anything about the product that they're
making they're letting them be
developers they're letting them make the
game that they want to make and they're
trying to support them in any way
possible so one thing that we've always
criticized you know thinking Activision
for EA for sort of the boardroom getting
into the design room and making
decisions and affecting the games that
we love to play so um they made it very
clear that their they've had the
opportunity to make the game that they
want to make and beyond that they've
said that because of this new
collaboration um that they're making a
better game that they would have been
able to make on their own and
specifically they talked about the
cooperation between first party studios
which is something that we've heard a
lot from like when you talk about Sony
and Sony Santa Monica and Naughty Dog
and all of these students about them
sharing with one another even not first
party stuff even second party um
exclusive stuff to PlayStation like
Vemma and stuff like that just ranting
things of that nature the collaboration
between these studios is such where
they're sharing their tech their ideas
back and forth
in a way that benefits all of these
games and it's something you don't
really see like if we've talked about
how Nintendo Nintendo studios don't
really work with each other unless
they're actually working together on a
game beyond that they're very sort of
isolated same thing we've had criticisms
about third-party studios that we've you
talked about how Bethesda came out with
you know fallout 4 and it seemed like
they were a little tone deaf to the
things that people wanted new and
fallout and it basically made fallout 3
again so it's like they sort of go into
this rabbit hole and don't pay attention
to what's going on around them so this
collaboration that in exile is talking
about it is interesting because I don't
know that we've really seen this before
on the Microsoft side this is something
that we haven't really seen from
Microsoft where there's and this is the
literal quote from one of the heads of
Enix Alice's we're sharing with all
studios I mean we talked to the guys at
the coalition if we're doing something
that involves shooting we're picking up
the phone and we talk to them if we want
to do something with water effects then
we're talking to the see if the room so
he said he say so everything is great I
mean everybody's like kumbaya and I want
to talk about this because I can just
hope none of them smoke yeah so I think
it's interesting because this is the
first time from Microsoft that we really
see that they're they're really doubling
down on this sort of familial sort of
sentiment between their studios and
sharing it back and forth and I think
it's only gonna benefit every single
game coming out of these studios because
when when you have so much expertise
across different genres in your in your
portfolio it would make it would be
stupid to keep them isolated from one
another
mmm this is deep Marysol them before I
jog I gotta get a lost salty in here and
oh man Gary Jackson next because um this
is new this is no kind of talk I'm not
even like used to this so salty man I
know I brought this to you and the dm's
like where are you at with this which is
it's in exile revealing things behind
the scenes it just sounds like nothing
but good things to me honestly cuz all
these companies have things that they
specialize in you know so if they're
gonna be able to share their knowledge
and information going back and forth I
think that's some of the reason why
they're trying to get some of these
developers to get in close proximity
with each other you know the new studio
what's it called the huge one - all-in
if you yeah they're in California and
stay there so it's a good thing to do
this and I honestly I wish it would have
been done before but you won't but if
you have some things that you want to
improve on like you say in the water
right it's a water water talk talk to
the people that are experts in it and
then that takes your games to another
level I think it's amazing I think that
they they're showing that you know
they're having the ability to have the
freedom as well and they're liking
what's happening behind the scenes
because people something worried about
that because there's a stigma out there
with Microsoft that they they meddle
with their developers stuff like that
which isn't true
especially with the new game Ninja
theorist game right there like it would
be multiplayer when that was the case
you know so I think this is good for the
future in the long run with the the
first party studios and and four-game
pass in general because I think that
they're gonna be able to do what they
want and if they have issues they'll
improve upon those and put out better
quality games you know Lord oh yeah I
got to speak to EJ because I see your
Twitter brother see they come for you
and you use the great analogy and
reference to like students in teaching
right and just like of what is expected
from the studios and stuff like that and
I think maybe you kind of say well we're
gonna have that tough love right right
well for the Xbox games dudes until we
see that quality but when you hear stuff
like this does just move you anyway when
you hear in Excel talking about they're
pooling resources stuff like that like
what's your feeling about hearing this
kind of stuff from Xbox games videos
there can be there can never be anything
negative from recognizing um culture
culture building yes right that's the
first level of culture building is
saying like there are things we have all
these resources why not
use them we're not gonna keep what we're
doing hidden from everybody and keep it
as it's ours no you want if you have
that Network use it you know it's like
we're not strong and doing this effect
but hey these guys are I mean as a
designer I do that all the time it's
like mm-hmm
I don't know how to do this let me hit
my boy up because it's like he's an ace
at doing it you know like how do I get
this line work to look right in
Illustrator you know or Photoshop order
case maybe no it's a beautiful thing to
hear that kind of thing and you you want
that studio culture like we've heard it
like from the Sony side like yeah they
do talk to each other but at the same
time guess what they do they push each
other yes that's what you want now and
hear that that's happening early and
already that's a great thing absolutely
you know what a dick man what do you
feel with a an Excel saying these kind
of statements are Xbox game studios what
you don't like Kulik saw was awesome but
I didn't know what the hell they were
showing at e3 so they could be making
RPG a first-person shooter could be
wrecking a racing game I would have
known mm-hmm let's pop you still got to
pump the brakes
how about Microsoft in general learn how
to communicate better how about that
like it's like we were talking about the
UM on brats podcast we're talking about
the whole you know whose fault is it
over not showing campaign I'm like look
sure I got something to say about that
but at the end of the day it's like
Microsoft approved that that's they
multi-million dollar stage Schad the B's
Games lady said this is size that Xbox
Studios is evolving
do you think it's at least a step in the
right direction at an amazing step in
the right direction but you know if you
you can have the best workers in the
world but it's imagine very on point
that it don't matter
fill of it listen oh I just got prove me
man
like you know it sure was great for e3
and and if you
really one of your technical was it
really great we had we had the studio
announcements that made it amazing but
besides that you know they didn't really
show a whole lot and then this year we
won't go into that I have faith in
Microsoft you know I think the thinking
as long as they can get I don't even
have an analogy for I'm just gonna say
as long as Microsoft can start to really
I'm hoping on my end that it's one of
those things where they're holding the
majority of their ammo for next gen
because what's the point in shooting
right are you generate toriel any would
not fail you say look you know it's one
of them things may all male was is that
is that Lord VZ is that the Lord of the
weapon well what's up girl
what's going on nearly absolute we're
just talking these topics right quick
man you guys you come in and hold us
down
quick question Lord peachy you know um
the comments from in excel at Microsoft
Game Studios I mean they just be Steve
started talking about how like they're
cooling resources they talking to the
guys over everywhere and see it these as
far as water and stuff and kinda like
collaborative stuff you know I'm saying
so like for the first time we're hearing
like Xbox game studios all in kind of
doing what's only kind of been doing it
ever in a way like did you hear that
number one and if not in like you know
what's your thought process on that when
you hear it like Microsoft Game Studios
kind of trying to work together I think
it strange that it hasn't been going on
I I guess I always just assumed it's
been going on this whole time I never
thought about it I just thought that's
like like they they kind of been working
on completely different Jon's emphasize
coalition in Halo like like what's
coalition gonna do hit up and hit a
playground like yo how do I make this
racing day like there's not a whole lot
of but now there's a lot more diversity
when it comes to you know multiple
people working around the same genre
that they you know their actual I do
scan conflictive each other
yeah yeah I guess they a lot of their
projects were pretty different but I
think the something that they could have
helped each other out with in the past
is like direction of their games like a
lot of these games didn't seem to have a
lot of like a clear path I've okay where
are we going with this game where is
this game edit and I think that's why a
lot of the games you know kinda didn't
end up as great as they could because
there was just lack of directions
thinking gonna help with that regardless
of genre no doubt fair now fair enough
like well I'm gonna double down I think
solve a lot of topic man I'll let it
talk me personally like I like to hear
stuff like this you know I'm saying
heading into the next generation dumb
pooling resources leveraging tank making
sure that they're cozy cohesive unit and
like BG said like kind of surprised like
this hasn't been going on for you know
there but at the end of day you have
that has happened now cuz in the past
almost felt like they was operating on
their own individual kind of island
right yeah yeah and now it's like look
if you're trying to build like EJ was
saying like you're trying to build this
cohesive unit you're trying to build the
identity as a brand studio cuz that's
been Microsoft's Achilles heel like
they've always had to outsource and by
you know I'm saying salty like they've
never you know I'm saying like you kind
of gotta establish that identity as a
brain say oh this is what it is that's
what we doing and my last point is like
I'm kind of with addict on this part too
which is like at this point for all
these studios being purchased that's all
let's get these next generation games
better bangers man I'm sorry I don't
ice considered an L don't like a liver
anything blow Nate not be out of the pot
but I need a couple of baggies for all
that I'm gonna need all right so though
there's only a couple Studios I'll give
it a little leeway like 75 to 8 but the
majority of these studios better be
booing 8 2 8 5 so I'm alright and the
mission if it doesn't do it below a nine
its L there because they have they
stacked that entire stable like crazy
there's some crazy people working there
they said something like our Drupal a so
you know it's funded and it's like so
few and then they have someone like you
know their I think his name's Daryl
Gallagher right it's like you say you
have him heading the whole thing I
expect some quality quality work that
better be the next Naughty Dog studio
like realtalk
what you know what attic is saying is
almost like when you just go into Madden
in the stack the whole team's waiting
room every time I see your tweet come in
and say hey we got this person from this
bootie or like you're you drafted so
like like ethics and that games better
be home run there is no it better be a
game with you consider off the Gecko
like just five minutes a game play what
I got a lot of flack saying the the next
gears but I better blow my socks off and
I got blowback I got people blocking me
me and following and being like not
become you know taking their patron off
I'm like all right no seriously dude
like I was praying like here's here's
the story I've been with Xbox its
forever right
oh gee Xbox I was standing in line at
Best Buy in the rain to get the Xbox one
I remember the day clearly right and if
you look at my gaming history I played
all the exclusives and I've beaten
pretty much all of them including Halo
Wars - right so if anybody's gonna talk
about the quality of the games needing
to be better I guess I could qualify for
that since I've actually been enthralled
so here's the deal like what I'm saying
Gears 5 needs to be at least you know
this or that this or that for Metacritic
or this or that and used to be quality
wise it's not just this game it's like
everything it's the whole big picture
it's the direction of the company and
all so yeah if I say it dis is the final
thing for me that's personally where I
draw the line because gears is one of
your peers tiller franchises and you had
gears for to play it safe you've been
saying all these things for
I need to see an 88 or iron man I need a
needs to be better and you did you need
to have game of year's nominees man I
don't want to wait till 24 more year
first let me pay this bill were quick by
dollar notes that dollar I think that's
pound right pound donation from debt
singer rprp geezers good be good for
xbox now though obsidian and ex our
masters I wouldn't be surprised that
they help on fable they don't need a
help on racers I don't know
did they come out openly and say that
they're they talk to coalition yeah bro
Oh tell him that statement I've never
seen this from Xbox game studio like
Garrett with all the studios and we
talked to the guys at Coalition and the
statement was the exact quote was we're
sharing with all the studios I mean that
we talked to the guys at the coalition
if we're doing something that involves
shooting we'll pick up the phone and
talk to them right and they make way
they must be making something else
because it kind of like the gameplay
doesn't fit if no idea maybe attributing
it like to waistline but the reality is
it's got to be also future projects as
well they can't just what the immediate
thing that's coming out as well and I
wouldn't mm-hmm I wouldn't mind just
going back to the I wouldn't mind
obsidian making helping what's a boy I
don't want exile because they're
completely different genre and and if
you have devs talking to each other like
that
I just dad I know you go ahead but I'm
just talking about like just from look
at it from like when you're talking
about from a standpoint general
experience there's a studio and let's
say let's use your bluff table right and
there's a studio in part of that
umbrella like we've know as much as you
can say whatever you want to say about
seeing these we'd know that water is lit
like you cannot take that away so
whoever's on a water physics team you
want me to get in pocket with them when
you talk and when you talk about the RPG
mechanics stuff I mean yeah you tell you
got to talk to obsidian and in exotica
these guys are masters of making deep
RPGs yes there are asymmetric RPGs and
not you
visually super impressive RPGs but the
underlying systems I think is a breath
of fresh air that fable could use right
oh I mean they can help him in more ways
than what what what you immediately
think they'd be able to help him I mean
they can help just little things like
you know coalition obviously if let's
say theoretically they know they need to
stay away from talking about anything
political that's for sure but
theoretically let's say that faith was
being made on the Unreal Engine like
playgrounds would benefit from talking
to the coalition because a lot of them
worked on all the old gears on that
system so though
let me get PG n real quick because BZ
like what letter you hear all this talk
right am i wrong would be like yo honey
bang is next generation from xbox game
studios like in my pocket
no really mean absolutely I mean I'm
expecting a lot of things from Alston
wheels in general next generation
because it's as far as I see it there is
no more like when it comes to hardware
limitations there's not really any more
for y'all with this with this what
they're getting right so there's plenty
of overhead for the other like do new
things and get things done and what I
mean by like no hardware limitation is
like we're at the point where they have
much more than they actually at this
unless you're you know trying to be dumb
and go for 8k or some nonsense
unreachable nonsense like that so you
know the whole resolution and frame rate
thing that that's not like a major thing
you should be concentrating on or it
should be the actual quality of the game
so yeah I mean I feel the same way
shout out my boy bull a top of the top
mid Jane next-gen is when we will see
the fire new games there's a [ __ ] next
gen I'm going to off myself man I know
you're adding you wanna rock up with
your a Final Fantasy 7 sir here yes let
me get up out of here before these two
everybody farms
but thanks salty for coming through
Thank You BG and thank you a tip coming
through so guys next week
Reynosa little brother together down
building let's get this next thing going
man lower back so get it Final Fantasy 7
it was rumored that it was a timed
exclusive now you could have took the
opening promotion and the promotion now
we have two wings you could have took it
one okay they they originally promoted
this game as a time to exclusive first
on PlayStation but now that's completely
gone they're not saying that usually how
that goes is neither one or two ways one
it's no longer time to exclusive and
it's coming out both on each switch that
does that's clearly not the case for two
it's no longer time exclusive and it's a
PlayStation exclusive it's it's looking
like you know as of right now which you
know there's been plenty of plenty of
scenarios to where people you know the
the quotes that they're PR team said we
have we're no longer what they didn't
say no longer they have no intentions on
bringing that game to any platforms at
that moment now they said at that moment
makes me think that you know it's
probably still time to exclusive
it's just Sony they're real like look if
you say some we coming over there we
pull it up okay we're gonna bring the
whole game you ain't even gonna be
around when we get there so I think
what's going on here is it's time to
exclusive for maybe a year probably a
year and you know once you get around to
the end of that you'll start seeing more
promotions on the Xbox version what I'm
thinking and what I'm saying is why is
this game even at I'm exclusive this is
such a big JRPG games there's no reason
and and I really feel like you know
Microsoft expansion at these time to
exclusives that they dropped the ball on
this one because this isn't just your
average game this is a game that's been
hyped for like 15 years like this isn't
the game that you miss out on even for a
year let's get salty a man like when you
see the stuff with Final Fantasy 7 you
know and then Square Enix doubling down
on exclusively for PlayStation where it
where's your head at
it's not the first time that we've seen
this kind of vague messaging when it
comes to exclusivity and timed
exclusives I think it's a cutthroat
business strategy for PlayStation
they've done it before here's here's a
good example of the difference between
one company and another Microsoft when
they had exclusivity for the the the
Tomb Raider reboot the remake it's maybe
they had a year deal on that but they
told everybody you know they didn't come
out and say hey this is exclusive on
xbox and just kind of leave it vague
they just they told everybody so
everybody's like well just wait a year
and then I'll go I'll buy it on
PlayStation or whatever well these
things it's the way you say things and
it gets people thinking because a lot of
the times even when they said hey you
can play a play at first on PlayStation
people thought it wasn't exclusive and
they were you know tweeting me and this
and that and everybody just thought it
was an exclusive already and then some
people just kind of have to read between
the lines but at the same time I tweeted
it out the best way for you to know that
you're gonna be able to play it like
because of the messaging is the by a
PlayStation if you don't have one or a
Playstation or preorder it on
PlayStation that's exactly what they
want we could to cutthroat mentality
they know everybody wants to play this
game they know the hype behind it so why
that's why they made it exclusive it's a
business thing and they know how to do
business and that's the difference
between the two companies right now
especially with marketing cutthroat in
the nature you know so o though being a
petty he said Square is tired of
publishing game or Xbox just itself 14
coffee
you got the amount only people that
would have bought the Xbox version of
Final Fantasy's the amount of people if
Eddie was all week live and what do you
think like you think he's on to
something
Burbage in between how Sony handles
their exclusivity versus on how you know
why you're so how's it yeah do but I
think at the same time screams is
probably like yo you don't have time for
Xbox gamers to be saying
before to come to getting past oh yeah
announcer but but cuz yeah you know you
know to MIT a you know you see it you
know you see it out there all right
nothing salt he's definitely onto it is
it's one of those things it's like it's
business and Sony is all about
PlayStation right now and whatever can
get people to focus in on what they're
doing and right now they're still for
the most part looking at traditional
like console means where Microsoft is
kind of going in a different direction
with it so I really chew on Brett
podcaster media bias always need to be a
discussion on oh like do you think we
waste only handles exclusivity in the
way Mike salty said like no one the rise
and Tomb Raider came out and then kind
of got in front of it
and they were like look it's one year a
lot of people okay we don't wait now
well sometimes in the Sony camp where
you see like a game like a street
fighter right know when she father yeah
it was exclusive and then even like as a
destiny fan like I've seen things where
like you know destiny exclusivity you
have to read between the lines to find
out like how long is the exclusivity of
the content and stuff like that so do
you think they're I want to say a double
standard in the way exclusivity is
presented or is just the way the
companies handle it is different I just
think like again it's the way that the
companies handle it I think like when it
comes to exclusive content I don't think
you're gonna see that as much anymore
but I still think something's gonna be
about that getting that third-party
exclusive deal because there puts the
focus back on their platform and do is
run around below this now right that's
not fair
sounds like get a PlayStation backs play
you really want this game of year ahead
of time if you really feel any like
they're you if you don't have one you
need to rocket one and I just I mean
that's how it has been for the longest
but you know seems like in the last
couple years we're on this thing what
people like it's not fair and it's like
a business again and sometimes and I
wish honestly I wish feel go about it
[Music]
like out of all the stuff that you could
have dropped the ball on you know making
sure kind of your platform us-saudi
coming underneath under the starts and
it take this time exclusive what the
track we don't know how much the truck
was back down you know we don't know
they got a good relationships not like
Sony and it's way like these guys
well they got a great relationship out
of it you know Microsoft's worked with
them on timed exclusives before
Microsoft's worked with them on getting
Final Fantasy 13 15 they're back I think
they're about to bring 14 like they got
they have talking with them to like it
could've easily what happened is Sony
hit them up first that's the only thing
that makes sense
mmm let's get busy in on this man like I
think it is going other platforms
definitely it is yeah I just honestly
what I think this is more about than any
you know contract or deal to have with
Sony I think even if there was no deal I
think this would only be on PlayStation
right now just offer the fact that like
yes you told my more than one platform
they barely have this thing finished for
work I don't even know when though the
rest of the game is coming out we can't
be thinking about like putting this on
another platform that's we can't even
get this out on one yet that's a good
point though I mean the fact that this
game is was they ending at Midgar right
the part one yet so it's like you know
you busy holding like yo we got a chill
conspiracy dude they got to get a team
together they could just finish the game
yeah I feel you have busy man but what
about like like how Sony handles
exclusivity versus how Microsoft has
exclusives like do you think there's any
differences there from the way sony do
it oh yeah sorry sorry treats their
exclusives like it's like it's the key
they came them like that's that's their
that's the best that's the way to
success Microsoft doesn't seek
exclusivity is the way to success so
that only treats their exclusives like
it's their game and my guess our treats
exclusives like alright you could play
it on our stuff but you know sooner or
later you could play it somewhere that's
a good point it's good playing fillies
come out openly and said like he doesn't
believe in exclusive deals you know I'm
saying like he's actually got in front
of that so it's it is a different month
saris to complete obviously they they
hold on to it's like it's their baby and
they they're willing to do that and you
know the messaging kind of still seems
like it's fermenting the same going into
why is it so different in the gaming
space versus anything else because
nobody's mad and they can't get stranger
things on Amazon Prime
oh no I want you brother no listen oh
don't get it twisted you know an
exclusive content person like I am all
about having compelling content that's
going to make you been me and won't take
up and always like oh I think you're
seeing a lot of that when it comes to
particular like they're in like their
first party stuff like I don't expect to
only see blacklist on Netflix right you
know obviously that's not their their
stuff really obviously they sign to get
that on their platform but they make
that right well I expect that somewhere
else like I don't know if you I've been
um like watching uh like you know that
pedant been doing a press run game this
past week and one of the things he said
on whether or not people just that you
know agree with it or disagree with it
something not being accessible to
everyone and not being available to
everyone gives it value absolutely
that's just the way it works whether you
agree with it or not that that's why you
know I think that a lot of new IPs
should should debut as an exclusive on a
console because it gets a lot more
highlight quite the scream that is
anti-consumer and its design might you
know anti-consumer would be like
offering you something like free to play
and then once you're locked in saying
okay now is gonna be $45 a month right
right you know flipping your script on
you that's best it's not the same thing
no doubt no doubt no these are good
points I'm waiting I'm with both you
guys for me because at the end of the
day again I'm from that era you know I'm
saying like you know Genesis had this
Super Nintendo have it you know I'm
saying so if you want it you can want to
give me a house to play or you ain't
copped and then get your reasons
all this it gotta be on everything I'm
not from that cloth I don't know nothing
about that because they're like it's
cool if some stuff is multi-platform
great saying it's got to be on
everything I'm saying Microsoft had to
be more aggressive to to their
competition in securing these and making
sure they're not at least by the time
exclusive on their on the competition
like look for stamp what's on like
hell-blade that I don't even know what
that game was came out for Xbox if they
didn't find engineers right I mean
listen it also kinda mean aggressive
tool if you review the first right if
you if Sony was ahead of the game in
kudos to them on that you know say it
could be a situation where they just a
little bit more aggressive with that
kind of said we know Microsoft's not
like there's a money issue right we
could assume that is not a money then
again that this game was it was locked
in and Phil Smith is back Parkin he
didn't get the key to unlock it yet I'm
not upset that it's not coming up for
Xbox I think it's a missed opportunity
and I think that you know there's a lot
like myself I gotta get another
PlayStation 4 game but I'm not one of
those people that I refuse to I will go
out and do it if I want to play tackle
by the game though you're I'm gonna play
Final Fantasy 7
and it's awkwardly on the platform
because apparently they think it was it
was relevant enough to go out and try to
make sure is that lease on all platforms
about the deficit with the file a suit
she had the Last of Us is already
question Lord Final Fantasy 7 fought
once dollars collectors $200 plus she's
never bought to $60 collectors 200 hours
plus way about finesse crown from
Nintendo did you get the one before that
death singer remember crash race to
mention of Xbox did you get that one he
hit that right now good yeah he has a
good point there you know when when the
crash was being announced it's like it's
like what we said it sony acts like that
IP is theirs when they market it was a
time exclusive like
remember what destiny like it wasn't
even theirs it was on the competition
platform but in the writing it said the
competition can't talk about it and
that's the thing there's again the
casual market tends to be the one that's
gonna gravitate embodies fresh eyes so
if they see a commercial and all they
see is it synonymous with Sony the
assumption is that you can only get it
even though that might not be the case
again because at the end all those
promotions when they say when they see
that PlayStation logo they they connect
that game that they just saw to that
PlayStation logo at the internet
commercial yeah Alti cutthroat marketing
I like see I'm from from that cloth so
it's weird you brother like that's what
I grew up with like you got it you got
it if you if you hustlin you gotta make
them come over here baby you got first
class Microsoft said they are no longer
interested in making people come to them
they're going to then now yeah so you
know that's a cool marketing slogan but
if they don't have those games that's
gin I don't think it's gonna work out
for me say if you need that kind of
deception you laid a F before you wrap
up real quick this is actually
consortium us his view on it and I just
want to get a benching in AJ and
reference to real quickly to the letter
because I wrap up we already did just
time which I missed out here it's five
smoking issue or nine issue well you get
out of gotta get your feedback oh
definitely a non-issue like is it's dumb
you know it's the reason why they
decided to take it I understand they
want to be in compliance with the e
League and everything like that but it's
it's just done because of the you know
the gratuitous violence but then smoking
is read so what are you teaching kids
you know like because they you have to
be consistent if it's about like not
promoting smoking to kids so does that
mean the game is from promoting
dismemberment and violence that's why
it's dumb I understand I wanted to be in
compliance the changed automatically
yeah but and then the other problem with
it was Rod Fergusson personalized it
when I was like oh my father died from
cancer from smoking cigarettes and all
day brah
you should have left that you should
have left it at that we're trying to be
in compliance with the ADA League
because of how now people could say well
I had a friend that's good violence take
all the guns up the game mmm chainsaw
chainsaw violence yeah so it's you
should have just left it as we're trying
to being compliant mmm
so last thing - before Bears eject in
reference as a point I made - in
reference to like the whole eSports
influence right you know the thing I
mentioned was just like I get nervous
sometimes when bigger corporate entities
like I'm all about the the developers
artistic vision right if he want to do
whatever he want to do like the house a
crow doesn't have easy mold or whatever
like I'm all about giving the developer
their right to have that choice you know
I'm saying them stick to stick to it so
with this kind of stuff like a BG like
do or do you worry about like corporate
entities kind of influencing game design
decisions don't worry about it too much
I mean it happens but I don't think I
old worry about it I think some people
you know bring it to the point of
conspiracy theory and they think
everything is influenced by some big
corporation when in practicality is
probably more influenced by like
individual developers in their feelings
and where they come from in life but I
don't I try not to worry about it too
much man no no Lloyd EJ what do you feel
about ask you oh well the first thing I
first thing I thought was I don't really
even remember anybody you're smoking
so I'm kind of laughing that the whole
thing and this isn't you know I'm saying
and I think was it the one character had
a cigar the guy from the new um yeah
okay so then I saw that and I started
thinking okay this all falls in line to
the whole eSports thing which me the
whole wave of gears roll out has been
towards we're going we're trying to get
that eSport crowd and
we see the numbers and we see everything
else that's why you're not seeing a
campaign because the fact rare
achievement still popping gears for when
you go through the campaign so they're
like why we gonna put that you know that
favor on what smoking thing to me was
like it wasn't necessarily a censorship
thing it wasn't it was not even like an
issue just like BG said once rod got out
there and made it like well like my dad
and listen and trust my heart goes out
to that got a we've all lost people for
a lot of things that go on and gain me
there's drinking ami I still don't think
it's censorship but it does low-key look
like you know a little bit of censorship
when it looks like it was deliberately
kept out of the game because of Rob's
personal experiences right on their
level yeah it definitely is but I was
like like BG said though now you've hope
you kind of put yourself on a slippery
slope where a lot of things can be
scrutinized right thing is the Raider
game so you definitely is it really
about that personal thing or is it
definitely more about the fact that you
were approached by the truth group and
they don't want to have the smoking
thing and you're trying to do the whole
eSport thing because I've had friends
die from gun violence mmm
you know I'm saying my father died from
alcoholism and all these different
paintings and all these things are still
a part of gaming I mean you got kids
running around in cartoony fortnight but
they're still shooting each other each
other I work in the school system and
we're actively training kids too high
for their life wow that's crazy
yeah all these things kind of go hand in
hand so it's like how much do we want to
go but at the end of the day
theoretically if Microsoft did even say
anything about it yeah they could have
kept it moving mmm not from an inner
defense attic right they were asked
right he was asked that's how this whole
thing came up or did it well what it was
is he he was he was going back and forth
people on Twitter gosh no it's like I
said it's that man's business if he
wants to do that that's up to him but he
needs to understand this the Internet
and people will twist everything you
have and from what you know first off
it's like it'd be different if it was
something big like gun violence roping
is nothing okay fine again we got it
like right at the same time
people will be like okay what else are
you doing like if you are so moved by
smoking how do we know you ain't doing
something else but if he would have said
anything at all none of that would have
even popped up now I feel that man no no
it's not my petty side I was like this
energy all over the place at y'all
because I mean Sony they censors to be
sister some butt cheeks
everybody's oh oh they're the worst that
are worse you know I think I think prior
Yosa was that I think that's two
entirely different so it is it really is
but one was put in the game and one was
it yeah okay that's like a sense had to
bring it to the realm real quick but oh
yeah we gonna get up out of here man
like I said we got a pole and we'll roll
out so I'll get new ILP polder return so
in regards to the recent Gears five
controversy involving the removal of
smoking as a narrative device how do you
feel about this decision moving forward
with the gears franchise the choices are
a not feeling it sets a dangerous
precedent and interferes with artistic
expression of developers be non-issue
doesn't affect gears gameplay in any way
operation well let's see I don't care it
is about to get smoked this holiday
without any campaign footage please Rock
the ILP vote when it goes up on Twitter
Lord salty is gaming Lord broken game HD
and Lord Eric Jackson thank you for
coming into rum and holding us down wick
and all the fine people finally start
with more salty we're gonna find people
find you what do you have going on sir
all right you guys can find me on at
saltiest gaming two words on youtube on
twitter it's salty streaming the eyes a
one to lots of people there this week to
get back to normal scheduling making
videos when the news picks up hopefully
and also the salty to me podcast
Thursday at 9 p.m. Eastern
Lulu on the new one in the round man
as we see burn for NORAD I already know
you got another switch light on on deck
coming through for the no one oh yeah
we'll see cuz my current daughter stole
my six-year-old she's a hardcore gamer
we'll see little one you never know what
they like or dislike you know yeah
hopefully it should be a gamer early we
got a doctor ping them yeah that's a
loose log overdue there's been a minute
man Laura BG comments from the world
later today what is going on with you
sir Shannon Brett yeah what more
podcasts will be uh later today at uh
6:30 so it's the 200th episode you've
been doing this way too damn long
clearly level two bugs are doing man
you're doing a long time setting the
standard the tomb weapon will podcast
any special topics any things we need to
look out for foot today just you know
what happened this this reason we're
different enough I know you already know
man that's my mayor a dissolute for
coming through all those they are much
appreciated sir
and of course Lord Erickson of the Brat
Pack has and giving perspective for me
undead what's going on man you say much
love was coming through man we're gonna
find people find you what you got going
on but yeah thanks for let me come
through appreciate it yep you can find
me on Twitter ICI Jackson with an x-man
same thing on xbox live same thing on
PSN not as anything else which that's
true phone numbers put together it's
been much would it as the easiest way to
find their perspectives as always
dropping the knowledge and fighting off
them that them Twitter phase hey keep it
all my honesty man they don't like you
be real since I know that lord hedak was
going on sir because I'm behind you uh
you can find me going to work and off
Twitter probably for the rest of the day
I'll definitely catch catch the 200th
episode of well sure Johnny thing
planned for that or you ain't gonna
really say anything right now
I don't regulate his way that's regular
no no no nope drunk but not like presto
right listen I've been to old 200
episodes and you just use kind of coast
and I'm keep a real key kind of coasting
appreciate everyone coming by definitely
at that like button if you don't mind
Liana [ __ ] definitely subscribe know
there's a couple people I know ain't
subscribe you know definitely been a
pleasure and I will see you next week
you already know man like I said shout
the saw be king they had to roll out
anniversaries and family oh my boy JD
game with the fire super shot great shot
great show guys Xbox forever get a
switch proto my man just get the X cloud
man shoutout to home King the brothers
we'll be back next week last some more
things playing a shout-out to salty for
the non rigged Marvel Ultimate Alliance
winning me I'm broke as a joke buying
all these diapers and stuff sup man it's
a blessing I appreciate it guys trust me
this was rigged I'd be winning it every
month believe yo your timing was
impeccable bro I was like he's gonna
laugh saw what he thought up that's
what's up babe it's now those in the
chat so you can still ooh he's the one
who drew your name from that yeah I
could blame smiled Oh any checks it's
not rigged oh no they already know so yo
check us out you already know king of
statues King you'll have a lot of stuff
up later already know the last word with
myself in the boxes on Fridays in the
mornings
please check out Lords of gaming dotnet
tremendous article my boy mods games
gonna have some fire Joshua reading and
of course my boy condors condor dizzy
the whole crew the host Dream Team salut
yo everybody please enjoy your Sunday
and on that note we are out of here
please